the actress Kirsty alley has died at the
age of 71 not long after being diagnosed
with cancer some of her best known work
was in the long-running U.S sitcom
cheers Ali's children paying tribute are
describing her as incredible Fierce and
loving Kamali hasmore
Kirstie Alley was a star of television
and film in the 80s and 90s her children
true and Lily Parker posted a tribute on
Twitter saying their mother had passed
away from recently discovered cancer she
was 71. they said that she died
surrounded by friends and family
Kirstie Alley was best known for her
role as Rebecca Howe on the NBC sitcom
cheers to joined the show at the height
of its popularity in 1987 as the manager
of the iconic bar a role she would win
an Emmy and Golden Globe for in 1991.
Ali also starred alongside Bruce Willis
and John Travolta in the 1989 film look
who's talking and it's two sequels John
Travolta posted this on his Instagram
Kirsty was one of the most special
relationships I've ever had I love you
Kirsty I know we will see each other
again
in the last few years of her life Ali
said she felt she'd been blacklisted in
Hollywood due to her support of the
former president Donald Trump her family
say her passion and zest for Life
inspired them to live life to the
fullest just as she did
Kamali Melbourne Sky News
Tim Allen paid tribute to Kirstie allia
on Twitter saying a sweet cell pass on
in Kirsty alley sad sad news prayers for
all her family Maria Shriver also wrote
on Twitter and you Kirsty for several
decades and interviewed her many times
this is such heartbreaking news as she
had so much more Life to Live she had a
kind heart and a great spirit she loved
her family and she loved life may she
rest in peace and Jamie Lee Curtis took
to Instagram saying I've just heard the
sad news that Kirsty Alias died she was
a great comic foil in TV scream queens
and a beautiful mama bear in her real
life
and from Taylor Lautner an honor working
with and getting to know you Kirsty rip